in Germany dozens of people remain in
custody after raids across the country
on Wednesday the targets were suspected
supporters of a far-right movement that
rejects the legitimacy of the German
State the federal prosecutors said those
detained fantasized about forming a new
German Army and installing a minor
Aristocrat as leader of the country
biggest anti-terrorism raid in Germany
for many years on Wednesday morning some
3 000 police raided more than 100
properties in several German states and
arrested 25 people all of them suspected
members or supporters of the so-called
reisberger movement their goal a coup
d'etat in Germany they wanted to
overthrow democracy the arrest is
suspects are united by their rejection
of State institutions in Germany
the arrested suspects believe in
conspiracy myths consisting of different
narratives from the reisberger ideology
as well as the Quran and ideology
the network was made up of both a
political and a military group according
to German authorities they had planned
to invade the German bundestag and use
violence Germany's interior Minister
Nancy feza said the investigations
provided a glimpse into the quote abyss
of a terrorist threat from the
reisberger
they're counted as a decent attack who
wouldn't agree on a day like today where
there's one of the biggest raids against
far-right's efforts aimed at attacking
our state that polarization is on the
rise and we have to defend our democracy
every single day
if they had succeeded this man was to
become the new head of state Heinrich
Royce a descendant of an aristocratic
family from Eastern Germany who still
uses the symbolic title of Prince
Heinrich the 13th the entrepreneur from
Frankfurt is said to be the ringleader
she would have been installed as the new
Justice Minister birgit mizak winkaman
who was a member of the German
Parliament for the far-right alternative
for Germany party until last year
she has since resumed working as a judge
at a Berlin Court efforts to remove her
from her position because of her
involvement with far-right extremists
failed earlier this year
but the court confirmed that she was
released from her duties on Wednesday
the rice Burger a far-right extremist
deeply anti-democratic movement its
members reject the German state and its
democratic system and are prone to
violence
German authorities estimate that the
scene consists of some 20 000 people
between 2015 and mid-2017 alone more
than 10 500 crimes are said to have been
committed by so-called geisberger
more on this joining us now from London
is Julia ibnaziz with the institute for
strategic dialogue and author of the
book going dark the secret social lives
of extra Miss Julia has the reisberger
movement been underestimated
okay
well to some extent yes I would say that
the the authorities in Germany have
increasingly focused also on the
reisberger movement and they created
actually a new category uh for
classifying anti-government extremism or
they call it democracy
legitimizing extremism uh last year in
2021 so there has been a rising
awareness because the movement has grown
and has expanded massively over the last
few years the origins of the reisberger
movement are already in the in the 1980s
but really in the last few years they
have really gained ground and have also
become more dangerous and radicalized
towards violence
okay you say they've become more uh
dangerous how dangerous are they
they are um well the problem is that um
we we have in Germany we have um 20
around 20 000 reisberger and five
percent of these are estimated to be
prone to violence according to the
police um and to the security services
so uh these are that means we have at
least two 2 500 people who might be
prone and of course in this plot we saw
that there is a very strong overlap also
with the Q Anon uh the conspiracy myth
community of Q Anon where we have also
seen um a high willingness to resort to
to violence not just in Germany but also
abroad in the US of course we had the
ties to the January 6 storming
um Capital riots and um in Germany we
also this is not completely new because
even a few months before the capital
riots uh there was an attempted storming
of the German Parliament and there was a
high involvement of reisberger and of Q
anonent here and there so this doesn't
really come as a surprise but it's still
shocking to see the the large scale of
this of this operation and of of this
plot
now the people involved are said to be
conspiracy theorists to reject the
modern a German state is there an upward
trend of these sentiments in Germany in
general you think
I'm afraid so yes because there is a
very
um unfortunately there is has been now
really a rising anti-establishment
resentment within the German population
that is of course mirrored in other
parts of the world but there is a higher
um there's a higher recruitment
potential for movements like the rice
burger and also Q Anon where we've
really seen these movements expand a lot
in in Germany and Germany was
particularly prone to these conspiracy
myths that are
um of course combining old conspiracy
myths of the reisberger movement and
wanting to re-establish the the
pre-World War II borders and not
believing in the legitimacy of the the
current state and the current democracy
and combining those old older elements
of the reisberger movement with new cure
non-conspiracy myths that then take this
onto a global level where they would
blame the so-called Global Elites and
would also often add anti-anti-semitic
elements to these narratives
now you have researched uh
radicalization on all both ends of the
spectrum if you will so what are the
main reasons for people to become really
radicalized
it's of course usually quite quite
complex and there's not one single
profile for people who become
radicalized towards violence what we've
seen and what I also saw in my in my
undercover investigations within
different extremist groups is that very
often individuals would face some kind
of identity crisis and that can be
caused and triggered by bigger crisis
like now with the pandemic and with also
with the
um of course the the war
um the the Russian war in Ukraine and
the economic and energy crisis in
Germany
um and and globally there has been a
really a higher proneness in the in the
population to becoming radicalized so
it's often
um of course these movements often offer
some kind of antidote to to loneliness
but also to uncertainty
um to a sense of a lack of perspective
that many people were facing especially
um with the social economic and also
mental health consequences of the
pandemic and of these various crises
that we've seen in in the past few years
Julia they're an expert on
radicalization and extremism thank you
very much for your time
thank you
physical correspondent Thomas espower is
with me now is now the prosecutor said
uh they expect more rest to follow what
can you tell us absolutely this is not
the end of this ring of this group and
according to what authorities have
released so far they seem to have been
at least relatively organized it was not
something that they had just planned in
the last few weeks it was a group that
was apparently formed at the latest in
November 2021 it had already a political
arm with a cabinet basically formed it
had a military Wing as well which was or
the goal of which was to not only
recruit people especially among the
German military but also to conduct
military training training with weapons
and we already saw in that report what
kind of people belonged to this group so
certainly a very important development
Yesterday by the German government by
German authorities in particular but as
you you correctly point out from what
we've heard so far this doesn't seem to
be the end more arrests are expected and
the investigations are set to continue
now a plot to overthrow the German
government how close were we really to a
coup here well that's something that we
don't know exactly but authorities have
pointed to the fact that they were
organized and in an advanced stage and
what I mentioned about the structures in
place that this group already had point
to that advanced stage and the fact that
they were also linked to this
organization the reitzburger movement
which is really profoundly
anti-democratic which rejects the
existence of the German State as we know
it so far points to the fact that they
had really concrete goals now how
possible those goals well that's another
question all together how realistic
those goals were achieving those goals
is another match altogether but they
were at least planning it and that those
plans were certainly according to
authorities in an advanced stage they
included Terror attacks probably that's
isn't that the real threat that is
certainly part of the real threat but it
goes beyond that it goes really
targeting Germany's Democratic
institutions trying to storm the German
Parliament trying to replace the German
State as we know it so it goes beyond
just Terror attacks it really affects
the German State as we know it and the
reichsberger scene which has been linked
to this group is actually known to be
prone to violence they have an affinity
to weapons according to authorities and
only last year there were over 1 000
crimes linked to that scene so that's
also a reason why authorities went in
those rates with over 3 000 officers and
why they believe there was certainly a
potential of violence there you
mentioned this reisberger movement
conspiracy theorists really who reject
the modern German State how prevalent
are these thoughts in German Society
well if you just speak about the rice
Burger I wouldn't say they're very
prevalent we're talking about 21 000
people that are directly or indirectly
linked to this the bigger question is to
what extent far-right extremist views
are prevalent in Germany and not only in
Germany but within German Democratic
institutions within politicians within
the judicature within the German
military that is the big challenge for
German authorities and that's the reason
why German authorities have said on
various occasions that the threat from
the far right from the extremists far
right in Germany is the biggest threat
to German democracy Now uw's political
correspondent Thomas Sparrow there thank
you very much Tom